thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
foreign
[Music]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
foreign
[Music]
hello hello everybody Welcome to daily
with Doc as everybody is coming into the
room and getting their audios and their
videos connected
if you are here live with us make sure
that you have that chat option open also
so that you can see all of the valuable
information that is being shared by our
lovely co-hosts with that we have with
us today so today we have sherry
Browning and also Marilyn bazera here
helping with the chat and letting people
in and making sure everybody is getting
connected
so again make sure that you have that
chat open if you're watching us live
stream come join us come to daily with
doczoom.com and you can join in on the
actual live presentation raise that
virtual hand that you can find if you
click on reactions from the zoom menu
and raise the hand so that you can ask
questions for Dr Wallach also we are
always always here to to help you Monday
through Friday from noon to one Pacific
time so do the math if you're in
mountain time that's one to two Central
Time two to three
eastern time three to four Atlantic time
four to five and if you are in South
Africa not South America but South
Africa then it's about 11 p.m your time
unless my math is wrong so my name is
Becca dukes and I am honored to be the
hostess of this program daily with Doc
where we bring empowering information
information that was a Light Of Hope for
me because I had so many things going on
that I had been told were genetic and I
would just have to live with things that
I had been pushed off to pain management
saying that I would just have to deal
with the pain the rest of my life take
pharmaceutical drugs if I didn't want to
be in as much pain as I was and many
other things I was allergic to I was
having very severe reactions that I did
not like the side effects well I was
listening to the radio or a friend of
mine was listening to the radio and he
called me up and say hey check this
doctor out let me know what you think
we'll talk about it later
so I did and I thought it kind of
strange because you know this individual
disliked doctors with a very
strong dislike
capitalized All the Above
and so I'm like okay why would he want
me to check out a doctor well guess what
this doctor that we are referring to
started out as a veterinarian his
patients couldn't tell him what was
going on he was also a pathologist and
he has three doctorates in pathology
where he was going around the world in
fact funded by the National Institute of
Health
25 million dollar Grant was the
accumulated amount of this study and
research that he had been doing
to determine
pollutions and how they affected the
body well he went deeper than that and
actually went into the nutrients and the
deficiencies of nutrients and how they
affect the body and folks
if it wasn't for the fact that I
experienced what I was experiencing
and went through
from barely surviving to now thriving I
wouldn't be here doing what I'm doing
today
I full hardly believe in this and I am
so honored to be able to bring to you Dr
Joel Wallach Dr Wallach you are one of
the founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics
that proves that genetic theory to be
incorrect
I just want to thank you for all of the
work that you have done
because if it wasn't for the work that
you have done
I wouldn't be able to be here on camera
with you
Monday through Friday
and help you spread this message so
thank you well thank you Rebecca and
thank you to your team and all the
things that you ladies and guys do and
um we're definitely making progress
we're picking up countries
um very very rapidly because you know
people are weary of just taking a
painkiller people were weary of just
taking something that um
uh causes you to or should I say a
little more flexibility or something
like that but over time things continue
to get worse it's really not dealing
with the the issues it turns out that
most of these things
the doctors have dealt with pain relief
and symptom relief over the years or
just simple nutritional deficiencies
they're not genetic and there are no
gently transmitted diseases
and
there are no we're talking about birth
defects we're talking about diabetes and
how would pressure and Alzheimer's
disease which we're going to talk about
today uh we're talking about arthritis
um we're talking about
um asthma we're talking about heart
disease cancer none of these things are
genetic or autoimmune in any way shape
or form and doctors just sort of made
that up to kind of cya kind of thing
um well you know the reason why we can't
deal with this is It's Your Body
attacking itself
no they just didn't know the answers so
they were blaming you up for being
deficient nutrients okay and because
nutrition does not occur in a uniform
blanket around the trust of the earth
that occurs especially mineral nutrition
it occurs in veins like gold and silver
and prior to
1882 or three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 on Pearl
Street in New York City on the bluff
we're looking at the construction
Brooklyn Bridge
when Thomas Edison pulled that switch
and started the first commercial
electric generating plant in New York
prior to that our fuel was wood
and coal for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years and people learned to
put the wood ashes and coal ashes into
our garden because wood ashes and coal
ashes are like 98 minerals and two or
three percent carbon
and grandma would put some of the wood
ashes into our food as a spice we're
getting minerals directly that way but
then at that time when we went over
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 to electricity
suddenly now there were no more wood
ashes and no more
coal ashes
and
this trans it changed everything okay
good you got you got the picture up by
Hell's Kitchen named after that terrible
District in New York City there you go
the terrible District in New York City
very bad thing in the world happens
Hell's Kitchen has a perfect description
of what was going on here at three
o'clock in the afternoon I was Monday
September 4th we've said that and then
it comes down to uh it's one of those
things where
we have to pay attention to all the
details here because we have to be
responsible for taking care of ourselves
um some of you are old enough to
remember bottom line
and prior to electricity Every Spring
when the snow and the ice would melt up
in the mountains the creeks and rivers
would fill and they'd get all the silts
and mud and dirt from around up there in
the mountains and they bring it down
into the valley and the it would flood
the valleys
and within weeks the flood water would
dissipate go down in the soil or go away
one way or another and relieve maybe
anywhere from a quarter of an inch to a
couple inches of silt that it brought
down from the mountains the farmers
would plow that back in renew the soil's
Vitality because the previous year all
their crops had sucked all the minerals
out of the soil and bottom line for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years was renewing
even before a man came along was
renewing these minerals
uh that came down from the mountains in
flood water so it's one of those things
where
um you know as a kid
I'm taking all this stuff in
and the story
is which they say ongoing
well we're continuing to get
misinformation from the medical system
it's really tragic
the things that go on with the brain are
not genetic they're not autoimmune
and they're the second biggest well no I
shouldn't say a second they're about the
third or fourth biggest cost we have
when you take them all together it's
about the second biggest cost
of all the disease we have so let's look
at some of these okay we're going to
look at some of these diseases uh let's
start out with one that everybody knows
Alzheimer's disease we spend 305 billion
with a B 305 billion dollars each year
just to treat the symptoms
of Alzheimer's disease
not to prevent it not to cure it okay
but just to treat the symptoms
305 billion holy moly okay
and then we have MS multiple sclerosis
okay which is a form of demonization
white matter the brain's going away and
oh bye bye 25 of your brain weight is
cholesterol and 25 percent of your
spinal cord weight is cholesterol except
the white matter of the brain myelin
and we hear them say oh they've got
demyelinating diseases and that's why
they have all the sharp circuiting other
nerves the the Transmissions fall off
the nerve before they get down to the
your legs and kind of stuff in the brain
and myelin is is cholesterol
okay and doctors made a horrible
horrible horrible
deadly expensive Troublesome mistake
over 100 years ago when they said oh the
blockages in your coronary arteries your
heart is your blockages your arteries
around your body including your kidneys
and your lungs and your brain your heart
are due to cholesterol plug in your
arteries nope it was from cooking badly
frying using oils like salad dressing
and cooking oils using margarine instead
of butter and all that kind of stuff
and getting away from cholesterol made
things worse okay so we have Alzheimer's
disease we have MS multiple sclerosis
gambarin syndrome gambray syndrome which
is multiple sclerosis of the spinal cord
we have Parkinson's disease which is
multiple sclerosis of Tremors and now we
got a new one uh okay FTD frontal
temporal dementia is basically
Alzheimer's disease that specifically
affect the temporal regions of the brain
and the problem region of the brain all
right or Alzheimer's disease is pretty
much the entire brain that is Afflicted
one way or another primarily
denomination and then of course
demyelinating diseases
now I have to tell you
that these are easily fermented
and they're easily reversed
okay and you have to take the 90
essential nutrients I like the
helderbrand heart pack which has 215
nutrients the the core is still the 90.
and I like the
um
synaptive three of those twice a day so
that your brain cells talk to each other
okay I like the I-26 which comes in
powder capsules and chewables okay the
I-26 it says right on the label contains
25 percent of your daily requirement of
cholesterol what is the only product in
the market in the world that says that
on the label contains 25 percent of your
daily requirement of cholesterol to
maintain your brain there's spinal cord
your peripheral nerves
okay so everything works because you
cannot function without cholesterol
and so when people started getting on a
cholesterol
reduced diets getting on statin drugs
lower the cholesterol all these things
started just flaring up and you know one
of the more recent ones is that FTD
frontal temporal dementia and the the
symptoms
are really extreme symptoms of Cambray
syndrome to me and Ms and so on
and also including the memory piece
and uh Bruce Willis just had to retire a
month or so ago because he had really
severe FTD frontal temporal dementia and
you know we're trying to get the word
out to him because I can reverse all
that these things are reversible
Alzheimer's disease reversible so why
don't doctors reverse it well
they're getting paid 305 billion dollars
a year just to treat the symptoms
do you want to kill and eat the dairy
cow
I already want to milk the dairy cow
every day
they're milking the dairy cow every day
by treating the symptoms
okay come on vodka is kind of hard isn't
it well that's factual remember our
Pathologists I've done over 32 000
autopsies
you know some projects you know like
twenty thousand one thousand seven
hundred those kinds of numbers
and it's not that I'm smarter than
anybody else but I'm more experienced
than most and I do have very what should
I say deep knowledge into things that
most people even other Pathologists
don't have they just don't have the
numbers okay and the diversity I'm
dealing with over
um
100 over 400 species
of uh animals
okay and with over 400 species of
animals and of course when it comes to
the brain there's 37 different diseases
doctors like to send you to all their
they send it to all their um uh
classmates and there's a
um CD that comes along with this it's a
book and a CD set
and and then we have the newest one it's
only been out for a couple of months now
the wallet Revolution it's a 75-year
track record okay a 75-year track record
of
our major discoveries there's a lot of
little discoveries that we don't have in
there and that's why you got to get a
hold of the book it's over 300 pages
okay uh epigen actually started a whole
new science epigenetics we shared a
whole new science
and a book that's in the Smithsonian
Institute of the National Treasure
has over one thousand I think it's like
1 300 Pages or something like that it
represents 20 000 autopsies
it's my thesis it's in the Smithsonian
this is a National Treasure I'm very
very proud of that that sells for twenty
five thousand dollars so most average
Americans don't get a copy
but you can go to Amazon say hey are
there any of Dr wallach's book disease
of exotic animals available for sale and
they'll show you some they're like you
can get them for eight thousand ten
thousand because the dog peed on them or
the the Connors are folded down and
there's writing in the margins and that
kind of an underline and so forth and
and so what we're doing now is we're
taking each chapter in that book disease
of exotic animals making it a book
instead of a chapter we're making it
into a book well its own references and
so forth the first one and it's not yet
quite out it'll be out in another week
or two okay the first chapter is on
primates and why it was the first
chapter in primates okay that's because
I really really got deeply involved in
this
when they fired me from your keys
Primary Center when I discovered the
first non-human case of ribosis
ought to be a genetics is it a birth
defect and this is me in 1976 okay 1976
that's me at your keys primate Center
was one of my
um
Reese's monkeys that had Cisco brosis
and they sent them slides they didn't
tell us from Milwaukee I just said I
think this is I sent five medical
schools the slides they said I think
this is what do you think and they say
oh yeah classic example and I told them
all this is from a monkey going into
space monkey Yorkie's Family Center
Emory University in Atlanta Georgia
and I think we can start a colony of
these monkeys you know they're gonna be
laboratory animals and they were so
excited then I said okay I got 24 other
baby monkeys that have it and they
um are not related to this original
monkey at all and all the story of
course and the Publications are in that
book called primates that's chapter
number one now it's a book and then
there'll be chapter number two and
chapter number three each one of them
will be a book okay so that's like 20
books
more books coming out
but the newest one right now 75-year
track record and we have so many famous
people on there okay going over their
story okay we're talking about Pat Boone
Danny Glover Andy young Theo Ratliff
Evander Holyfield and you know I could
go on and on and on but you get the
drift these guys are telling their
stories oh uh Kelly Herron a female
um All-American basketball player okay
and she had terrible terrible stuff
going on and she was still going to the
University of Tennessee
and she came to one of my meetings
because you know I was in the local
radio stations when I was there giving
talks and so she came and told me her
story and we kind of rebuilds her and
within a couple of months she was able
to get her position back on the team and
she became an All-American
okay All-American basketball player for
the University of Tennessee so very very
proud of that that's a Kelly Herring you
can look her up
and so don't forget Allison receives you
want to eat three eggs twice a day
um soft yolks soft scramble and butter
soft poached soft boiled I have one for
three for breakfast and three for dinner
time and then I have my I-26
25 of my daily dose of cholesterol and
lunchtime I like the chewables because
they can take them with me so I don't
have the powder all over replace and
three more pills I have to take okay so
I like the chewables and they don't
taste bad they don't they're not sweet
or anything like that they don't have a
lot of sugar on them they're just sort
of what I would call Pleasant
and even little kids like them isn't
they're not bitter or anything like that
and so that's giving you the cholesterol
you need to maintain the brain
now again in a couple of months I'll be
84. and most people say come on molecu
you know it's not like you're 50 60
years old you can't be 84. well yeah I
am okay I only had prescription drugs
for three days out of my entire life IV
antibodies because I had a puncture
wounds falling in a a trench up in
Canada construction trench that
punctured all over the place so they
gave me Ivy I really didn't have a
choice it put me in the hospital gave me
IV antibiotics
but they wanted to cut my legs off I
didn't know I'll dive my legs on you're
not gonna cut my legs off so I still
have my legs
now I'm saying these things because we
have so many programs for 600 different
diseases
you have 5 000 products
we do a 600 different diseases and the
first ones were named after animals
because I was treating people and I was
I was not a physician I was a
veterinarian and I knew I was going to
get in trouble as a veterinarian
training people so I put you know the
pig pack on the Healthy Start pack name
okay the pig pack says well this is a
pig program and you know if people want
to take it they can no problem and then
I had the pig arthritis formula
okay
and then we got so many I just you know
I could only do so many things with the
pigs
and so
then we have the Hair Skin and Nails we
have the the
um you can see here the blood sugar pack
we have the older daily classic tablets
for higher pressure it's one of those
things where
again we treat over 600 different
diseases now this freaks
doctors out
because they called their patients they
say hey we haven't heard from you in a
couple of months where we've been you're
supposed to be here for your appointment
well I don't have another pressure
anymore what what do you mean you don't
have it anymore it's a genetic thing no
I don't have it anymore I've been taking
this um Healthy Start pack in the ultra
daily classic tablets and my high blood
pressure went away in just a couple of
days well don't you need dialysis
anymore no I'm urinating three times a
day and three times a night I don't need
dialysis anymore either
you know I hadn't urinated in 10 years I
was taking dialysis six days a week but
now just after a couple of weeks on this
program
I don't I don't need dialysis anymore
and so this has gone around the world
and we're I don't know how many
countries are on now I think probably
85 countries now up until a couple of
months ago we're only on 80 countries
but the number of countries has been
going up and I'm very excited because we
have a whole new uh project coming up a
whole new project coming up and this is
bringing other countries in because it's
freaking them out do we have answers for
things that they their doctors believe
were genetic anonymous because they were
taking
the information from European medical
schools and doctors American medical
schools and doctors and the information
was incorrect
the diagnosis was correct but saying
that it was a genetic disease or saying
that it was an autoimmune disease about
to take himself was incorrect to simple
nutritional deficiency diseases
and we figured out a way to get it into
people uh comfortably they don't have to
come in for IVs and injections or
anything like that and we have
these programs the basic programs say
the Elder brainer heart pack has 215
nutrients in it and then we have all
these
adjunctive things to add to it you know
healthy blood the sweeties for blood
sugar
all the daily classical pressure
we have the let's see here collagen
peptides and the MSM and glucagel for
arthritis and osteoporosis those kind of
things and then of course we have
synaptive for things going on in your
brain and spinal cord
and you know in memory FX and you know I
could go on and on and on but of course
we have the digestive enzyme for people
with irritable bowel syndrome Crohn's
disease celiac disease all these things
are totally reversible
all of these things are totally
reversible and we're so very excited
about this and people are coming to us
from around the world now and a
landslide okay
the Landslide on land and a flood on the
Great Waters so with that said I'm going
to turn it back over to Rebecca and see
where we're at here
all right well thank you so much Dr
Wallach I totally agree that
you know what we put into our body or
don't put into our body especially when
it's something that is needed to thrive
you're not going to get the results that
you're hoping for when it comes to
growing old gracefully so Dr Wallach all
of your research that you have done has
been instrumental in changing lives
around the world
is it we're all made from the Dust
yeah it doesn't matter
what your color your skin is it doesn't
matter there's a couple of instances
where gender does matter okay because
women don't have prostate glands and
that kind of stuff
and boys don't have ovaries and so forth
but you know other than that kind of
stuff
everything's the same and it's one of
those things where it doesn't matter
when you have horses whether they're a
palomino or a white horse or a black
horse or a paint pinto horse we take the
skin off it's all the same underneath
the skin and so what works nutritionally
for a white person works for a black
person what works for a European person
works for an Asian person
and so on and so this is why this has
gone around the world like crazy because
you know we we're on
zooms all over the world you know just
earlier today I was doing a zoom into
England and Spain
okay and so that was kind of fun I do
regularly zooms into Australia New
Zealand
and to the Philippines and and so on uh
and so I do zooms All Over America and
Canada
okay and it's one of those things where
they just keep coming on and on and on
and on and uh looking forward to the day
when none of these diseases will exist
because everybody will be taking these
nutrients and avoiding the bad stuff
saying maximize absorption that's
another piece you do have to get rid of
the bad stuff so you can maximize
absorption efficiently
and because if you if you put in your
mouth it's coming out the other end
because your intestines are dead because
you're eating gluten and fago Pyrenees
what are fetal Pyrenees well fago
Pyrenees are things that you find in
buckwheat and you'll see right on the
label the buckwheat bags and boxes and
cams and so forth
gluten-free which is absolutely true
but they have fago pie rings in there
which they don't put on the label and
most of them which are worse than gluten
they destroy your intestines and the
phagopyrenes in buckwheat produce lupus
and contribute to rheumatoid arthritis
and all these other things that are said
to be autoimmune by the medical system
which are really just nutritional
deficiency diseases
okay and so they're easily gotten rid of
we're going to try I don't care if
you've had room tourism for 45 years you
give me six weeks it'll be gone
or maybe sometimes in two weeks
um
same way with um
things like uh well I've said Allison or
disease we already said those kinds of
things in the brain those things go away
very quickly
and
um rheumatoid arthritis you just take
our healthy Bone and Joint pack okay how
they want to Joint pack
to give the bones and cartilage and
tendons and ligaments what they need but
then you also have to throw in
the Minocycline to kill the bug
mycoplasma which caused it to be
um the arthritis rheumatoid arthritis
and then all of the rheumatoid threats
will go away because it's not a unimmune
to thing they're killing you same way
with lupus it's not an autoimmune thing
it's just a you know celiac disease
irritable bowel syndrome skin disease
dementia it's all part of the
lupus thing and you know we get rid of
Lupus in weeks I don't care if again
you've had for 20 30 40 years it goes
away in weeks because it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease not
autoimmune
well I love the fact Dr Wallach that
there are secret sauces in those
thousands of products that help us to
have that digestive system that can
function properly and helping to break
down those fats and those proteins and
those carbohydrates and
give the body the the bile
how many people Dr Wallach that I come
across who no longer have their
gallbladder well the doctor told me that
I wouldn't need it it was just causing
me some digestive issues so they took it
out I'm like well did that solve your
digestive issues
uh no actually they got worse
because you no longer have that bile
that breaks down the fats
and you cannot absorb fashionable
vitamins like i a d e and K and
essential fatty acids for respiratory
stuff preventing blood clots and strokes
and stuff like that do not let them take
your gallbladder out what we do if
that's already happened we had the
gallbladder in a bottle okay it's called
our ultimate enzymes ultimate enzymes
it's a gallbladder bottle it has has
bile in it it's actually in the bottle
and so I take two of those three of
those twice a day depending on what I'm
gonna be eating that day I'll take a
minimum of two probably 75 of time three
of the ultimate enzymes twice a day and
if I'm really going to really have a
steak for breakfast something dinner
I'll take three three with each meal
okay
and you still have your gallbladder oh
yes ma'am
out of my body
so it's just giving your body that extra
support I take the enzymes with each
meal
um and there are sometimes folks where
we eat way too much and we're just
feeling bloated
one of my favorite products for that
there's actually two of them one of them
is called digest FX and the other one is
microbiome both of them and then oh
there's a third one root beer belly
they all help to ease that discomfort
because it's adding more of what the
body needs to break down that food to
create that
so that's in the stomach that's supposed
to be there
heartburn and acid reflux is not because
you have too much acid it's because you
don't have enough and the food is
sitting there and it is fermenting and
causing issues
well let's get that food digesting
through the body so that the nutrients
within it can then be absorbed we can
eliminate
and and have a you know a great life
right doc
absolutely
we have to be proactive and do our thing
and I think you know that's that's the
message and again
this is why this book is so important
the Wallach Revolution
okay the walk Revolution
75-year track record of our major
discoveries and many of these
discoveries were on very famous people
and so they're telling their own story
and many of them most of them are
telling their own story and some of the
famous people are telling not only their
own stories but stories of other famous
people okay that led them to you that's
correct
and then there's those of us who you
know were not so famous
and that's okay because well ninety
percent of the people we take care of
are not so famous they're just an
average American which are the greatest
of peoples okay the average American are
great people
okay and they deserve the best of the
best of the best Dr Wallach stop for a
moment
we're not here just for Americans
that's true
we're all over the world
yeah the average human being
is a great person oh yeah
I okay I do know that
thank you thank you because I don't want
to leave anybody out and for those of
you who are not so great people it could
be because you have a really bad
digestive system and that gut brain
connection is being hindered and toxic
and you need the nutrients too so that
you can also be part of this great
Community Dr Wallach is talking about
so Dr Wallach I just want to thank
everybody for being here with us we've
got a full house and we have hands up
I'm so excited now folks as you are
watching this program whether you're
here for the live whether you're
watching a replay whether you're out
there on Rumble YouTube or Facebook
following us here on critical Health
news because this program is being
sponsored by critical Health news but it
is
oh I got to get all these shows right Dr
Wallach maybe with Doc
um brought to you by daily withdoc.com
if you were invited by this to watch
this program by somebody specific make
sure that you get back with them
and they might have a special way of
ordering Dr wellick is going to be
mentioning products
the best place to get the products folks
is not just online where you find
somebody but the person or the
newsletter that provided you the
information that helped you find this
program
all right you get it from a big box
outlet online somewhere you are not
going to have that personal service and
customer service that you would get from
a health coach and we have a full team
of health coaches if you have never
spoken to anybody about youngevity or
any of the products that Dr Wallach is
mentioning we have a call team standing
by at
855-949-3377 so let's go to the first
hand that is up and forehand welcome go
ahead and mute yourself
oh hey what's up guys uh thank you for
taking my call and everything yeah you
guys do
so I had two questions if there was time
the first would be about egg whites so I
eat egg whites is that a problem or
should I not take them or eat them at
all or maybe a couple hours before after
um a meal can I take my minerals or just
avoid egg whites your egg whites you
want to take them well with uh breakfast
and dinner
I weigh 142 pounds and I take three soft
poached shakes okay sometimes we soft
scrambled in butter but I'd say about 80
percent of the time they're soft poached
and then 20 of the time to solve
scrambled in butter not margarine but
butter
and I've been doing this for like
75 years kind of thing okay
egg whites and egg yolks are good for
you just don't eat them raw
okay
okay sounds good thank you so much I
have another question for about my
cousin she is five foot five inches tall
120 pounds
she has lupus
acute kidney injury or disease she's on
dialysis three times a week she has
headaches all the time
dizziness sometimes
weakness in the legs and pain
and she wakes up she she mentioned
waking up once or twice
to use the bathroom at night time I
don't know if that's daily but when I
when I asked her she told me that
okay lupus okay is secondary to
consumption of gluten okay it's multiple
nutritional deficiencies it's not an
autoimmune disease all right well you
said that earlier
um dialysis means that they've got
problems with their kidneys arteries
okay so the not the kitty can't filter
the dirty blood because they can't get
the dirty blood okay
so let's see here do we say how much
this gal weighs
yeah about 120 pounds 120 120 pounds
okay I wanted to get rid of all the bad
things they have a book it's called Uh
Dr Walsh cooking without the bad foods
Dr Wallace cooking without the bad foods
and
um it has 300 pages
of
um safe recipes and also safe cooking
methods
Dr Walsh talking about the bad foods
very important that's the basics you
kind of sit away from the bad foods
because otherwise you're killing your
intestines and just taking supplements
on top of dead intestines don't work
very well
then 120 20 pounds she's right at that
cusp just turned out with one healthy
brain and heart attack per month but
half of those earthing twice a day she
needs two bottles a month of the MSM she
can take three of breakfast sweet lunch
at dinner time to support and promote
major pair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes bone itself
then I also want her to um
have the uh let's see here synaptives
you can take two vowels a month of that
so you take three breakfast three dinner
time cheese three eggs twice a day with
soft yolks she's the I-26 at lunchtime
she could have say one or two of the
chewables or two or three of the
capsules and for the lupus I also want
her to throw in in addition to all that
I want her to throw in the
um Hair Skin and nails hair skin and
nails and the skin issues will go very
very quickly the nail stuff will go away
quickly so she's got to stay away from
all the bad foods and the bowel problems
will go away okay because the bowel
problems are contributing significantly
to the skin issues and the Brain issues
and so forth
and um to go along with lupus let's see
I think we covered lupus we covered
um
the
let's see here we I think we cover most
of her issues including
uh diabetes and all that kind of stuff
and dialysis and okay
okay sounds good thank you so much Dr
Wallach
all right thank you so much farhand for
coming on with us Dr Wallach let's just
move right on to the next hand that is
up and Miss howdy go ahead and unmute
yourself
Grand Rising good afternoon thank you
hello
Dr wallet if possible I have two women
one of them uh she's 46 years of age
she's five feet
220 pounds
she had been diagnosed with
anyway she has stage four c k d stage
four kidney disease
uh black gallbladder issues
she's taking cholesterol meds diuretics
high blood pressure and diabetes
I have a pressure in diabetes
okay we have to appreciate that being
overweight if she's five foot oh she
needs to you know weigh 100 pounds
so she's 120 pounds overweight
I want her to get one
of our keto Shake meals a day it's not
it's a meal replacement it's not to add
to a meal it's a meal replacer and it
comes in chocolate and strawberry and so
how would Harry get you know half of her
month on one flavor half the other
flavor so she alternates so it's not
boring
then that's the keto Shake again it's a
meal replacer it's not to add to a meal
they don't really have two healthy brand
hard packs per month the Heather band
hard pack has 215 nutrients the core is
still the 90 essential nutrients I want
to have a full dose of everything twice
some a month that's two Health brand
hard packs per month I want her to have
two thousand months of the MSM so you
can take three at breakfast three at
lunch at dinner time that's going to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between
vertebrae bone makes one itself I want
her to take three of our ultimate
enzymes the breakfast lunch and dinner
that'll be three bottles a month of the
ultimate enzymes okay we call it the
gallbladder in a bottle
okay it actually has bile in it to help
absorb
um vegetable vitamins
also the healthy essential fatty acids
and so forth all right then I also want
her and again the
gallbladder in a bottle the ultimate
enzymes because she has uh her
gallbladder removed okay and then the
hybrid pressure owner to take and also
for the dialysis I want her to take the
um
ultimate daily classic Channel it says
three words ultimate daily plastic
challenge I want her to take three at
breakfast three dinner time there's two
bottles a month
and that's going to help her blood flow
through the brain the heart to kidneys
every place else
and then I also of course she has
diabetes whenever you get two bottles a
month of our sweetie you shouldn't take
three at breakfast three dinner time
that's two bottles a month
don't pull turkey off the medication
either for the Habit pressure or the
diabetes but as the blood pressure
begins to come down she can slowly
reduce medication based on the numbers
as the blood sugar begins to come down
she can reduce the blood sugar
medication based on the numbers
I always tell people give me 90 days
you're going to see a dramatic
Improvement in most cases many of these
things will just totally go away now
here comes the ultimate question how
long do you have to stay on all these
nutrients forever
far ever you can reduce the amount a
little bit you know you go from 220
pounds down to 100 pounds okay you can
cut all my doses down in half but you
can't give them up
when can you go without oxygen never
once you go without water never okay you
cannot go without these essential
nutrients otherwise you'll get back in
trouble again within months you don't
just put dirt from Texas in your car
because there's bound to be some oil in
it you put high quality oil in there you
put transmission fluid and you put brake
fluid in you put antifreeze in and so
forth you
you take good care of your car most
people take better care of their car and
then take better care of themselves so
you do have to take these things
specifically don't think you can get it
all from your food you cannot you cannot
get much from your food
oh sure so that's what this last
um client she has
some type of cirrhosis
uh she says it's okay she has primary
by Larry cirrhosis
vestibular migraines
to wait a minute she got primary she got
primary
liver
yeah primary binary
biliary biliary okay cirrhosis
vesticular migraines
okay so you got headaches
and uh oh and she has
um dermal fibrosis
her skin dermal dermals yes
okay night sweats and joint joint pain
and she's
uh 46 43 a hundred and
64 pounds five feet two
okay
and that you know answers are two more
questions uh you know how many times did
she wake up at night to urinate once
three times five times ten times I also
wanted to know she had a no a zero for
okay good that's good and then I also
want to know if she has any tinnitus or
ring in the ears or voice changes she
has a lot of numbness
numbness in her hands numbness and our
hands and feet and feet okay yeah she
could have osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the spinal cord
okay and so that's all possible and you
say she weighs 164 pounds kind of
something like that yes
okay gotta get rid of all the bad food
she needs drones cooking without the bad
foods 300 pages of safe recipes and safe
cooking methods and then she's two
healthy Brandon hard packs for months
two how they're burning hard pressure
ones photos selling twice a day I only
get two bottles a month of the MSM she
can take three breakfast sweet lunch at
dinner time they're going to help a
Rebuilder joints
um cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between vertebrae
bone Wings bone itself including the
skull and also the bone marrow to make
white blood cells and antibodies and so
forth I also need her to have our
ultimate enzymes she could take through
those twice a day okay it'll be two
vowels a month so it's going to help her
absorb nutrition okay and let's see here
um
foreign
I also want her to have three eggs twice
a day for her brain stuff okay migraines
I also want her I could be osteoporosis
of the skull and doctors are diagnosing
it as migraines but it's obviously a
process of the skull
um
is he here so I do need her to take the
I-26 take our I-26 she needs a three
doses a day the eye 26 it comes in
powder chewables or capsules and she can
you know I I take three of The Jewels at
lunchtime myself is how I take mine all
right
so let's go there uh oh and also she
needs our rebounder sports drink she's a
rebound of Sportsman for energy our
sports drink has 100 nutrients and
rebound
okay has 100 nutrients in it Red Bull
has one mineral in it
one mineral magnesium we have 75
minerals Red Bull has four
vitamins we have 25 vitamins amino acids
in there okay and so she needs at 164
pounds I'd have her take
a minimum of two maybe three of our
rebounds a day and it comes in in
canisters okay and it's you know
a cancer like this powder has 36 doses
in it comes an orange box it has
um 30 of these sticks in there and the
powder and the sticks have the hundred
nutrients and they're including the 75
minerals and then of course we have cans
but the cans do have carbonation in them
so you have to pop them I popped two of
these at night before I go to bed put
them in refrigerator and by morning all
the bubblies go on they're flat and so I
have one with breakfast and I'll have
one around
noon or right after the radio show here
that kind of thing before three o'clock
but after three four o'clock you might
keep you up all night
okay and so this is you gotta work hard
you got to give your body everything it
needs you can't just say well I'm eating
well
it doesn't work
it killed Bruce Lee the famous Fitness
Guru at 32 he died at 32 of a heart
attack
because he believed the doctors who told
him don't waste your money and take
environmental just exercise
okay and eat well and he did take he
sneaked took one mineral magnesium
on it
he was very he was very short okay of
being complete it's still working
Dr Wallach is it possible to tell me
what Bill Bill Larry cirrhosis
cirrhosis is scar tissue of the liver
the bile duct system is called biliary
system it's all the little bile
production of in the liver that bring
all the bile down to the gallbladder
okay that means the liver is undergoing
cirrhosis okay
and they don't have to be drinking
alcohol to have biliary cirrhosis okay
it's a new it's due to a nutritional
deficiency
yeah
and if you're if you're not getting bile
into your intestines absorb nutrition
and you're not supplementing with the 90
essential nutrients to get nutrition and
you're eating gluten wheat run around
oats that's why you're in trouble you
have all these bad things going on it
results in all these bad things
okay okay make sense thank you
yes it makes perfect sense I appreciate
it okay
because these people heal very quickly
if they do this exactly as we've said
and avoid all the bad stuff you have to
do both you have to avoid the bad stuff
as well as take all the good stuff okay
yes yes
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and here we want to try we got Stevie
who came over from YouTube you Stevie
you have a quick question for Dr Wallach
go ahead and unmute yourself
okay okay
thank you
so uh-oh audio's not connected
I see that she's trying to speak let's
try one more time
okay can you hear me yes ma'am go ahead
with your question
thank you I am okay so I am totally new
I have seen you two days ago just for
the last 15 minutes because it popped on
my screen I have a younger voice and I
look young but I'm 61. I am 5'5 and I
weigh
216 down from 265.
um I was under extreme chronic stress
um it's like a bad B movie I had to
sleep with a gun literally beside my
head to protect my grandma uh it was a
year and a half of hell I had such
chronic stress that it squished my
arteries I'm sure I'm sure I'm missing
what you have and I'm not hearing this
is what I'm telling you my arteries got
squished I don't have high cholesterol
but I had a heart attack and then they
told me because of my stress I got
diabetes then they gave me a plethora of
medicine and now I have dementia so I
just kind of weaned down on the medicine
I'm only on metoprolol 12.5 milligrams
and a baby aspirin and that's it because
we only have we only have seconds here
so you have you have diabetes or a
medication for diabetes
uh metoprolo which I'm not taking
anymore okay uh let's see here you have
dementia okay now this uh difficult to
remember things
because of the medicine
they gave me medicine that made me
forgetful and then I tested as dementia
mild
okay how many times a night you wake up
to urinate once three times five times
uh maybe once and not every night okay
and you had a heart attack did they give
you a name for it was a Cory Mobility
heart attack or was it a blood clot
heart attack what kind of heart attacks
you have they just said my arteries
squished because of so much stress I
asked them they just said I have heart
damage it was the seventh of last
November and um I have angina every day
and I take um Nitro uh when it gets
really bad and I'll understand okay so
let's let's get going here we gotta get
rid of all the bad stuff that got you in
trouble no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils I see no process Meats I'm
talking about ham and bacon and bologna
and salami and hot dogs and pepperoni
and jerky and all that stuff's got to go
okay no oils no sandwich you know
cooking oils absolutely no wheat bread
oh so I don't know such things as good
oats there aren't those other things of
gluten-free oats the gluten and oats are
small gliadin but it's still gluten and
then no buckwheat buckwheat does not
have any gluten in it but it does have
Faygo f-a-g-o-pyrenees in there which
are very very bad worse than gluten no
sugar of any kind absolutely no carbon
or drinks even the diet one's got to go
and also carbonated water bubbly water's
got to go because it neutralizes your
stomach acids so you cannot absorb
nutrition
then
um and digest food then of course you
need salt we have the Himalayan salt
back in now we also have the season
itself from Australia we have the
Himalayan salt from the Himalayan
Mountains they have over 28 almost 30
something different minerals in there
should salt your food to taste with
those do not stop taking salt you cannot
make stomach acids without salt
hydrochloric acid makes requires
sodium chloride okay if you have a
doctor who says stop taking
um the salt get a different doctor then
you also need to take ultimate daily
plastic count it says three words
ultimate daily classic tablets not
ultimate daily towels but ultimate daily
classic Talos and I want you to to take
those three twice a day they'll support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the heart the
kidneys everywhere in your body okay and
so you get the blood flowing through
there and blood pressure comes down
everything works better including your
liver and the liver has an enormous
capacity to heal itself but you got to
stop taking all the bad stuff which is
the main cause of all the liver damage
the biliary cirrhosis okay no nutrition
and all the bad stuff that's why you got
biliary cirrhosis I have no salt I don't
take any oils you should be taking salt
salt is Himalayan salts I don't take any
uh junk food sugars and um the only
thing is olive oil and
um fish dish oil no no oil with anything
nothing no oils
okay any oils yeah give them to your
doctor
okay with love
where do I I I'm not this is also new to
me where to the store that I go to and
what are the books that I need to get
and how do I learn okay Rebecca tell her
on the air so everybody else here is it
too what numbers should she call to get
a hold of the books and also the
products
all right Stevie
youngevity
you may go to daily with
doc.com and there you will find contact
us and one of our certified holistic
health coaches can help you get all of
the products that Dr Wallach is
mentioning or design a protocol
specifically for you so Stevie thank you
so much for jumping over from YouTube Dr
Wallach I know that you have to get
going we appreciate your time with us
thank you so much have a fabulous day
and everybody
we're here because we care
we're here because we have felt the
results from the products that are being
spoken of and Dr wallach's philosophy
and the research
that has been brought to us
through many different Avenues you can
find Dr wallick's books at
drjwalik.com that's
d-r-j
wallik.com and that is the best place to
get Dr wallach's books because all of
his Publications can be found there
and he also has staff there at Wellness
Publications that can help you if you're
not doing the whole internet thing you
can go ahead and contact them and let me
give you their phone number because it's
in the back
of the wildlife Revolution is a list of
all of his most popular Publications
even all the CD titles which we're
getting those put into
um audio
so that you can do a digital download
but the number four
drjwalik.com for wellness Publications
is eight hundred seven five five
four six five six so if I could have my
co-hosts come on with me today I just
want to give them a special shout out as
everything went nice and smooth I
greatly appreciate all that they do in
the background so we have Sherry we have
Marilyn and we have Ruth Ellen Sanchez
all of these ladies are so instrumental
in making sure that this program
goes without a hitch now we've learned a
lot of new technology the last few weeks
and Ruth Ellen
has done absolutely fabulous as we do
all of this troubleshooting and getting
everything figured out and if you have
technical skills and you have not spoken
to anybody about youngevity products and
you're looking to make a little bit of
extra money and use your skills
when it comes to technology when it
comes to computers
any of those things we are looking for
help
okay I'm throwing that out there we are
not afraid to ask for help because Dr
wallach's mission
goes Way Beyond us
we are part of a community and we
welcome those who want to be part of a
community and share their god-given
skills to help
their community and go beyond their
community so go to daily with doc.com
use that contact us and send me a
message and say hey I have skills let's
do this I want to help or get back with
the person that shared this program with
you and they can help you get connected
into the systems that they have as well
so again my name is Becca Dukes shout
out to all of you great coaches out
there who are spreading the message and
helping others find Better Health
in a world where we are just bombarded
by convenience which is empty null and
void of the nutrition that we need not
just to survive but to thrive until next
time bye for now
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
foreign